(audience cheering)
- Get it out.
Get it out.
I'm so excited to see y'all.
It was so weird.
Y'all were all in my
living room last night
with me and my kids watching it.
It was so good.
So what do you think,
we've decorated for y'all?
We did good and evil.
Do you like our audience dressed up?
(audience applauding)
Yes?
- It's so amazing.
Evers and Nevers.
- I know.
So in the movie Kerry
and Sofia Wylie are good,
and Charlize and Sophia
Anne Caruso are evil.
I'll do that with you.
So were you guys more into
like princesses or witches
like growing up, everybody?
- Ooh.
- I liked both.
(agreeing with each other)
- Isn't that kind of like
what the film is about, too?
Is that like there's room to love it all.
There's room to embrace
the evil and the good in you, right?
- What's interesting is I feel like
I liked the princess story.
I liked those as a kid,
but I like dressing up as the witch.
- Hmm.
- I don't know what that means.
I'll talk about it later in therapy.
- [Kerry] We can unpack that for days.
- Yeah. I've probably
been doing it for years.
But anyways, so Charlize and Kerry,
the two of you,
you're an elite group
of women in Hollywood.
Like people love you.
We love everything you do.
And you do such huge
films, the both of you.
We know you so well, TV, everything.
So what made you gravitate
towards this project?
- Well, I am a single
mom to two little girls,
seven and ten.
And my repertoires quite dark.
- [Kelly] Monster. What?
- Yeah, yeah.
- They didn't like that?
- I have a feeling they'd
have to be at least 52
to see any of my work.
(laughing)
So there's a lot of mystery there.
It's like, why do we see mom on a set,
and she's always covered in blood?
So this felt like I could do something
that's a little bit of
a love letter to them.
And they saw it with me in
Rome a couple of weeks ago.
Oh my God.
Like you know I'm gonna be 50 soon.
And I was like, I thought I
was jaded and dead inside.
Like I wanted their approval so badly.
It was almost, I had to re-watch the movie
'cause I barely watched it.
I was just watching their faces.
- Yeah, their reaction. Yeah.
- Yeah. So I really
wanted to do something.
I also, I really love Paul.
I had worked with Paul.
I was lucky enough to work
with Paul a couple of years ago
and had such a great experience with him.
And then this cast and
the story was really,
it was a big world and fun.
And we were all coming out of lockdown,
so I think we were just,
this felt like such a gift
to be able to go and play
in these costumes coming out of COVID.
- Yeah. It's so cool.
It is funny 'cause I have two kids too.
I'm a single mom too, and it is funny.
All that you do,
it's so funny what counts to them.
- Yes.
You're like, wait, I've done
like some really cool stuff.
(speaking over each other)
They don't care.
I know they're impressed by
the like it's, it's like,
but of course they're impressed by this
and what a cool thing to be a part of.
Like a series.
But what about you?
What about, what about your kids?
Like with the film?
- Same answer.
I mean I really, I was very
much drawn to this cast.
I loved having the opportunity
to work with Charlize.
I mean I, we didn't really know each other
before we started filming.
We knew of each other obviously
and we'd met a couple places.
But, we got on set and it
was like instant chemistry
because we're both working moms
and because we both were
wanting to do something
that our kids could watch.
My kids are not watching "Scandal."
- What?
They don't wanna know about the white hat?
- No
Not yet.
So it was really so wonderful to-
- That's what you think.
- Yeah, I know, I know.
(Kelly laughing)
But it was great to kind of drop in,
and also I feel like everybody
really made each other better.
Like we all loved this project
and loved this opportunity so much
that we were able to play.
Like really play on set.
- I love any time like parents and kids,
a whole family can sit down
and then a discussion happens afterwards.
About it.
About like good and evil
and what does that mean?
Like I have a six year old boy, too.
It was just, it was really cool
like how it kind of motivates
different conversations
that you didn't really
think were gonna happen
with your kids.
- But without hitting
you over the head, right.
Like you don't feel like you're in school.
You don't feel like you're
being taught anything,
but it does make you think
about things we should
all be thinking about.
- Yeah.
Sofia, so you started acting
when you were really young, right?
Sorry Wylie, both of
you did, but Wylie, yes.
So were you into it
like right off the bat?
- Yeah.
I didn't actually start
acting professionally
until I was around 11 or 12 years old.
- Well that's young.
Where I'm from, that's young.
- That's the crazy thing.
I always felt like I was so behind
because all of the other
kids I was working with
had been doing it since they were infants.
So I was like, oh I have
to like step up my game
and like really catch up.
But I always had such a
passion for performing,
and I had this big imagination.
I grew up with like this
alter ego named Berna
who had fire powers and had a
pink bob wig and cop glasses.
And I just was always performing
even if no one was watching me.
So I think this is definitely
something I was always
passionate about even before
I really knew what it was.
- You're creative kid.
That's awesome, yeah.
Well Sofia isn't the only one who was,
I love this video,
entertaining when she was young.
Here's Sophia Anne Caruso getting
ready to perform as a kid.
Listen to what happens after
her dad introduces her.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
I would like to introduce to you
Sophia Caruso.
Now Sophia will be singing
"God Bless America."
- And now I won't.
(cheering)
- I love at a young age you were like
I will do it when I want to.
I feel like it reminded
me so much of my daughter.
I was like when she was
like, not on your time sir.
I love, I love that.
Were you always like, did you
always kind of know yourself
like that when you were a kid?
Like when you wanted to do
something, when you didn't?
- Super rebellious.
As soon as somebody
tells me to do something,
I do the opposite.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Ever since I was little.
- Reverse psychology.
Your parents must know
this trick well, okay.
- Yes, yes, they do.
Yeah. As you can see in that video.
And also with my character too.
She's kind of like that, like
she's the good girl and then
she's suddenly the bad girl.
She like goes against the grain.
- I love what you just
did with your shoulders
'cause like you walking through
like on the little sneak peek we did.
I was like, okay, music video.
Like she is ready.
I was like that was, it was so cool.
- When it gets to slowmo.
- Yes.
- So badass.
- Yeah.
Charlize, for those who
don't know the story
why don't you explain like the movie.
What's the premise for everybody?
- Oh wow.
Well the simple concept
is that there's a school
for good and a school for evil.
- [Kelly] You don't say.
(laughing)
- And we happen to be
the deans of each school.
I'm the dean of the school for evil.
What a shock.
Like my oldest daughter was like,
oh Mom, ugh again.
The only movie they've ever
seen like a little bit of
was when I played the
Evil Queen in Snow White.
And she's like, ugh, can
you only do that part?
She's like, can't you
like do a different part?
I was like, oh my god.
My children are like,
just wear a dress, please.
- It is different though.
It's so funny, 'cause
whenever I found out you were,
I was like, they're different.
Even how you, it's like, it's almost like
even how you introduce
yourself at one part
in your, your, everything is different.
Your mannerisms, it's interesting.
- There's a lot of ways to be evil.
- Yeah.
- But anyway-
- And she seems to find them all.
- These two young ladies get dropped
in what they think is the wrong school.
Just to find out that
maybe how they see themselves
are not actually their authentic selves.
And it's the discovery that you
can't just be all one thing.
And so we are all a
little bit of everything,
and so we saved the day.
- They had nothing to do with it.
(laughing)
- All about us.
- Yeah, you really killed
it there at the end.
And I remember what happens.
I was like, yes.
- The COVID hug.
- Yeah, it was good, it was good.
(laughing) I just remembered the, yes.
I was talking about something else,
but I just remembered like, oh good.
Yeah, it was really good.
Oh my god, I love it.
So Sophia and Sofia's
characters are friends
who are set up to be enemies.
How do you think the dynamic
of that kind of plays out
in real world as well?
'Cause I felt like, I
don't, and maybe it's just
in the musician world.
I don't know if it's the
same in the acting world.
But they always try and pit
females against each other.
They do in the music world at least.
And I thought that was
kind of interesting.
- It's funny, yesterday
we were doing an interview
and somebody said,
you guys have such great
chemistry up there.
Did it feel competitive?
And we were like, what?
Like no, it felt so inspiring.
I think was the word you used.
Like which was so great.
It was, it was, we kept
upping the ante for each other
and encouraging each other to play
and find new ways to do the scene.
It didn't, it didn't
feel competitive at all.
- There's just been so little
opportunity for us, right.
And so the little that did come around,
instead of acknowledging
that there was a need
for more opportunity,
they made it about women
not supporting each other.
And I think it was the easy way out
because I have never been more supported
than by the women in my life.
Inspired by the women of my life.
Been brave because of
the women in my life.
So we just need more opportunity.
We need.
That's why I love being
in this film because...
(audience cheering)
Just being a part of something
that can create opportunity
for like these two young ladies.
To see them in this film,
makes my old dead heart feel...
(laughing)
We need more of that.
- This is their film, you
know, the two of them.
And for us to be able to
support them in these roles
where we're really just really amplifying
their incredible talent.
They carry this movie,
and we're so proud to be
a part of something that
shines a light on them and
all of the young people
in that film.
(audience cheering)
And what I really wanted to touch on too
is, I thought it was cool, like sometimes
you see like females
taking over, you know,
characters from books that
were males originally.
And I love that the book
originally has all this
like female empowerment in it.
There's plenty of roles.
There's males too, but I just-
- The guys are great.
They're always great.
- They are, they're great.
But I just meant, I found it interesting.
It wasn't like they had to go in and go,
oh we're gonna recast this as
a female to be more inclusive.
It was like, it was already inclusive.
And I found that really cool.
- One of the coolest
moments of my career so far
was after we shot one of the big scenes
where we're like introducing
the rules of the school.
And in a break, Lawrence Fishburne,
who's one of the cool guys in the film,
he comes walking across
the hall, and he said
watching you and Charlize
up there was so much fun.
That's why I did this movie.
(speaking over each other)
- Was it like intimidating at all?
Like to work with him?
Or just inspiring?
Was it, was it cool?
(laughing) Tell me more.
(laughing) I'm just curious.
- I don't think I was intimidated.
I didn't really have
time to be intimidated.
And there's always something to learn.
Whether your co-star
is famous or not famous
or legend or not.
I think there's always
something to be learned.
- How about you?
How did you feel?
- I was the exact opposite.
I was like freaking out.
I mean, look at them.
Like I've grown up
watching the both of you.
- I'm not that old.
(laughing)
- Like from a few years ago.
- Exactly.
And I tried to play it so cool.
I was like, hey Kerry, was up.
Like casual, yeah.
But inside I'm like literally shaking,
and I just remember like
the first day on set
I had with you Kerry,
you touched my face in one of the takes.
And I literally went to
my parents and I was like,
I'm never washing my face again.
(laughing)
- I love that. I love that.
Welcome back.
We're here with Kerry
Washington, Charlize Theron,
Sophia Anne Caruso and Sofia Wylie.
(audience cheering)
So together they star in
the new Netflix movie,
"The School for Good and
Evil," which is streaming now.
Everyone in our audience
also has chosen a side.
Good or evil.
(audience cheering)
Okay. So you're both
in the school of evil.
So what's one bad thing you've done
that you've gotten away with?
Ooh, fess up on national TV.
No pressure.
- I mean, well the other
day I did steal some limes
from a restaurant.
- Wait, is that stealing?
Am I?
(Charlize laughing)
- Are you more evil than you knew?
- Wait, is that stealing?
I feel like they put them
out there for you to take.
- No, no there were like
lime trees in the restaurant
with real limes, and I
took like four of them.
Just like shoved 'em in my pocket.
- That would be stealing
- [Kelly] That would be stealing.
- That would be stealing.
- It's like half stealing.
They put it out there.
You're coming there to
consume their products.
- It's a tree.
- It's a product.
You might be able to justify that one.
Kind of steal, stealing.
(audience clapping)
- It's just a lime.
- Watch out for her in your
restaurants, everybody.
What about you? What have you done?
- I, well I don't know
if I get away with it,
but I have maybe more than on one occasion
gone to take pizza at a kids' party
before the kids got fed.
Claiming that I was getting it for my kid.
- Oh.
I 100%, I did that the last
birthday I just did with my son.
- Okay, okay, good.
(speaking over each other)
- And part of me is like, why
don't I just say it's for me.
But then I feel bad because
it is like before our all the,
the kids just get so into the party
that I'm like this beautiful
hot pizza is going to waste.
- I know.
And they let it get cold while they're
jumping on the trampoline.
- Yeah, exactly, they don't care.
(speaking over each other)
And I'm like, the cheese
is like nice and hot still.
- So what about you?
Even though you're school of good,
have y'all ever done anything
that you've gotten away with?
Oh, I thought we were
gonna get a good question.
(laughing)
(speaking over each other)
- No, that's boring.
- Yeah this is, okay.
(laughing)
What about you?
What have you done that
you've gotten away with.
- I was just an odd
kid and so I, you know,
they do this weird thing
with girls' outfits.
They don't give you pockets.
And so I loved collecting
things, collecting rocks,
like anything that I
found pretty or sparkly.
- Collecting, stealing,
collecting, stealing.
(laughing)
- Exactly.
And I think it was
around like from the age
of like three to five.
I'm like three to seventeen.
No, three to five, I would collect rocks,
and I would just shove them in my pants.
(speaking over each other)
- I'm taking from the earth.
- Virginia Wolf.
Sorry, wrong person.
Sorry.
- So that's the most
evil thing you've done
and got away with?
(speaking over each other)
That's certainly not the
most evil thing I've done.
(laughing)
It's just what I chose to say.
- What about you?
You're not getting off the hook.
You're not getting-
- I feel like we need to
break for a commercial.
(laughing)
I don't know.
I mean, I feel like the,
I was mostly a good girl.
The evil things, I don't
wanna admit on television.
- Amen.
- You know what I, when I was
little, I used to lie a lot.
And then I found acting.
Because I had like such an imagination,
and I would just make up stories
about like what my family
did over the weekend.
And my teachers would be
like, it's so interesting.
And my mother would be
like, that never happened.
But then I realized I
could use my imagination
in ways that wasn't evil and hurtful.
- Way to take a negative and
make a positive out of it.
Nicely done.
(audience clapping)
A professional liar.
You get paid for it now.
- Yeah, exactly.
- That was just your pregame.
I like it.
- Yeah. I like it.